so rise of powers of X is amazing and
the ending of this is so awesome it's
it's absolutely mind-blowing but what
this does is this opens 10 years in the
future right the Tower of nimrod the
lesser the human machine monolith on
Earth and what we end up doing is
picking up with what isn't effect the
annihilation of pretty much all of the
mutant population there's very few that
are left here and in fact this has a
huge number of callbacks to everything
that's happened so far so starting with
Sentinel and the nature of like Enigma
the dominions all that kind of stuff
let's explain this cuz I think it's one
of the things that a lot of people are
curious about so dominions are basically
the end result of any kind of
technological advancement in any
particular Universe reaching its final
form and it's like an amalgamation of
artificial intelligence it's the reason
why as we saw over the course of
immortal X-Men and things like that that
the goal of sinister was to basically
make four clones of himself and they
were all going to go go forward and they
were going to learn everything they
could about any particular form of
information that's out there of power
right magic and science and all that
kind of stuff all that information that
was gained by Dr stasis and the Mr
Sinister that we thought was the only
one who had the diamond on his head
mother righteous orbus Stellaris those
four clones of sinister all the
information they gained was at all times
being sent back to a central database
and the intention was for that database
to achieve a kind of sing ity right
self-awareness and that when it achieved
that point it would become a Dominion it
would transcend all space and time and
exist out there Beyond virtually
everything one of the things to know
here is Omega Sentinel comes from a time
when that was in the process of
happening that Inferno issue number
three what we learned is that in the
future she comes from that in effect
mutants had wiped out pretty much all of
humanity as well as anything related to
machines right so Rod Sentinels the
whole nine yards and in fact mutants had
ruled the entirety of the solar system
and even the Galaxy there came a point
where there was an effort by Omega
Sentinel in humanity kind of a last
ditch effort to basically call in
dominions right to literally reach out
and to basically say we as Humanity have
achieved technological advancement you
know come and find us right the truth is
that they were lying but the idea was to
bring the dominions in and in doing so
the dominions would wipe out the
entirety of the mutant population given
how powerful they were the result was
that the mutants ended up channeling the
power of the Phoenix force and wiped out
all the dominions right at least those
who showed up in their Universe Titans
if you want to call them that right just
these giant robots right literally giant
space robots it's kind of crazy but
basically she's been trying to prevent
that future from happening ever since by
wiping out mutants here the reason why
she's been working with orcus the entire
time since the beginning of Jonathan
Hickman's X-Men run the kicker about all
this is that even when her and Nimrod
leave and they talk about this idea that
tomorrow is when they meet their new
gods they intend to summon a Dominion to
the universe because what that will do
is it will allow humanity and machines
to merge with the Dominion and then just
kind of become one or become part of
something much bigger than themselves
right it's like the Borg from Star Trek
more or less and so what they do is when
they leave you end up finding out that
Emma Frost while she is kind of hanging
on and died almost immediately after
they left she had used her telepathic
abilities to trick Nimrod and to trick
uh Omega Sentinel into believing that
there was nothing else there that it was
simply just her now how she managed to
use her powers on Nimrod in that
capacity I'm not entirely sure because
historically speaking telepathy does not
work on robots in Marvel Comics but be
that as it may we end up finding out
that basically mystique and Gambit are
here as well and they're the last two
but they were on a mission to gain
information and what they done or at
least what Gambit does is using his
ability to basically ignite kinetic
energy from potential energy he kind of
blows an escape hole that gives Mystique
the ability to contact professor Charles
Xavier and while it is successful and
she is able to relay to them the
information they need for the mission
they're on which we don't necessarily
know what it is yet she of course dies
in the process which makes sense right I
mean this really feels like 1990s Comics
I'm not going to lie the other thing
that we learn is that all that's left of
the mutant population on Earth is what
you see here and even then one of them
is not actually a mutant so Professor
Xavier is here but it's not really
Professor X instead what we're told is
that his body had been ravaged by his
powers and so sink is holding on and
holding him together sink is of course a
mutant that has the ability to
effectively channel the powers of
anybody else and so what it looks like
is sink is playing the role of Professor
Xavier and maybe Xavier's Consciousness
is in there somewhere but he's basically
using telepathy to kind of act as Xavier
Tony Stark has long since been dead and
all that's left is an AI imprint in an
Iron Man suit he doesn't actually have a
face or a body or anything Kamala Khan's
here for reasons that nobody understands
and then you have Shadow tiger right
basically Kitty Pride who had achieved
the death seed now the thing about the
death seed in Marvel Comics is the death
seed and the life seed you never really
see these and for a time they were cool
especially during the dark angel Saga
what was it uncanny xforce that was an
amazing story oh my God we need to go
back and cover that man like when he
rescues apocalypse dude that was so dope
man it was dude Strife oh my god dude
that was such an amazing story but in
effect the death seed it does have a lot
to do with celestials and stuff like
that we don't have to go into all of
that suffice it to say with regards to
Kitty Pride it modifies and amplifies
her powers to a degree but it also
twists her personality so much so that
she kind of becomes Thanos likee in the
sense that she basically worships death
and sees death as something to be
pursued as opposed to somebody in
possession of the life seed which is
pursuing the idea of life and then of
course you have Wolverine right and
there Wolverine Wolverine always lives
he's always here and so following that
you switch over to the orcus forge which
is out there in deep space now because
this is a different timeline outside of
the main Marvel Universe it's entirely
possible that unlike what we've seen in
the X-Men Comics up to this point the
destruction of the orcus forge and
seemingly everybody therein that in this
universe they seemingly survived and
actually moved beyond the Sun and went
out into deep space where they couldn't
be easily found by the mutant population
well the important thing here is there
is a conversation unfolding Mora MCT
tager comes along and she says I saw
something similar in one of my lives and
my sixth life it was 1,000 years from
now here now incredible and the response
of Omega Sentinel it is Moira A Simple
Plan really I brought the knowledge of
the technology from the far future where
the mutants defeated us to the present
day where they're unprepared it took 5
years to build what we needed and then
we aimed it at Mars five years of it
working and now we have a world mind it
will attract a Dominion who will bring
us into the larger hole all our data
part of a perfect machine outside of
time and space the response of Mora MCT
tager finally safe now here's the thing
about Mora mctaggert right and it's one
of the things that kind of threw people
off and I do think it's worth reminding
people here right Mora M tager for the
longest time in Marvel Comics was just a
mutant geneticist that's all she was
right a mutant would show up on the
doorstep of Professor Xavier and say I
need help learning how to use my Powers
he wouldn't understand how those powers
work so we'd take them to Mor mctaggert
and mor mtag would run a whole bunch of
scans and then say here's how their
powers work Xavier would take that
information and if they join the X-Men
develop a training regimen and then go
forward from there the big change that
was made to Mora mcag in recent years is
that she's a mutant and when her power
activates every time she dies the
timeline resets seemingly the entire
universe reset it was a little Cloak and
Dagger in the beginning when Hickman was
working on it and we didn't know the
full scale and totality of how things
were impacted but going through the
events of Inferno the later stories
during Hickman's run and even during
sins of sinister when she dies all of
the timeline resets and goes back but
because the events transpire that led to
her dying in the first place that
Universe becomes an alternate reality
now right so every Universe where she's
reborn that becomes the main Marvel
Universe right we're currently in her
10th life right the 10th life of Mora
MCT tager and so the cool thing about
this is while they are trying to draw a
Dominion to this reality or to this
universe and in turn they're trying to
join this Dominion right one with an AI
Singularity basically that they're met
by Dr stasis now Dr stasis is wildly
interesting here and in fact what's
going to happen at the end of this is
going to completely and totally blow
your minds and so what happens when Mora
MCT tager asks him right like why are
you here he says I know I know don't
worry I'm doing my job if you can't beat
them join them you don't need to slap me
down like philong however I come with
good news another of the ex teams are
down wiped out the bad news is they died
having breached certain files including
your personality imprint of philong now
didn't fa long know where you were
keeping quote unquote he who must not be
named the response of Omega Sentinel
immediately beef up security right
they're going to be coming here and so
at that point you basically pick up with
the X-Men who were on their mission Iron
Man shows up here right to this facility
and while you know there's higher levels
of alert than there were before at the
end of the day you would expect Iron Man
to be able to hack through this
information even if it's only an AI INF
print it still has all the knowledge of
Tony Stark it can't do it not only can
it not do it because of the security
systems the entirety of the Iron Man
suit explodes at that point in that
moment orcus becomes aware there's an
intrusion on Phobos right basically the
mutants are there trying to gain
information this leads to basically
Nimrod and Omega Sentinel traveling
through a portal and responding but what
also ends up happening is they activate
the world mind on Mars which Begins the
countdown of basically drawing one of
the dominions to this universe right
basically absorbing all sentient life
and then moving on to the next one the
cool thing here is we follow Dr stasis
and what he does when he transitions to
this new location right basically to
Ecuador The Vault down there that he
actually gives us this kind of
realization or this Revelation he's
seemingly the creator of the children of
the Vault and this is huge now here's
the thing it's an alternate reality
right this is a this is 10 years in the
future and as you guys will see this
timeline will meet its fate but we don't
know if this is like a giant alteration
that Marvel's making to the original
origin of the children of the Vault or
if this is unique to this universe but
for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with the children of the Vault
because not everybody saw our videos
about that comic the children of the
Vault were the result of literally
putting them inside an actual Vault
where time passed differently and the
result of this is that for like every
one day I think it was that passed in
the real world it was something like 500
years or something along those lines
that passed inside the Vault but
basically they're hyper rol evolved
right so on Monday you could fight the
children of the Vault and then on
Tuesday they come at you again with a
whole new set of powers and look almost
nothing like they did before because
they're just hyper evolved not only that
they're actually Advanced enough to be
able to figure out what it was that
killed them and then the quote unquote
machine Mainframe if you want to call it
that right like the center of the Vault
the thing that kind of runs everything
it'll basically bring them back and
it'll evolve them in order to make them
IM IM to what it was or at least give
them powers that can help them overcome
what it was that killed them before so
the children of the Vault are
ridiculously overpowered I call them God
humans right that's really what I refer
to them as but the reality here is that
with the X-Men and their mission on
Phobos because of the fact that it's
drawn the attention of orcus orcus sends
in seemingly everyone they can right
virtually everybody like Sentinels the
whole nine yards so this massive battle
breaks out on Phobos the kicker about
all this is that Nimrod and Omega
Sentinel are watching this and the
biggest threat that Nimrod sees is Kitty
Pride now this is for a couple different
reasons the first is because in more
recent X-Men issues for those of you
guys who have not been reading or
watching our videos right maybe you're
new here kitty Pride as most of you guys
know can just phase through solid
objects and stuff like that she's become
this rediculously capable assassin and
so the idea of her having the death seed
which amplifies her abilities and then
already having the ability to phase in
and out of stuff she could basically
survive this whole battle right she's
like a one-woman army and so immediately
Nimrod analyzes the nature of her powers
which Nimrod can do and then analyzes
the most suitable way to defeat her
which is also what Nimrod can do boom
knocks out Kitty pride and one Fell
Swoop right she's not dead but she is
incapacitated and so following that what
you do is you switch over to Omega
Sentinel and you get this kind of cool
explanation right World mind initiation
World mind stable World mind attempting
contact World mind contact achieved it's
reached out and successfully made
contact with the Dominion the Dominion
arrives and so again this is one of
those things where creating a world mind
will draw the attention of the Dominion
because it's like waving a giant flag
right and saying we have achieved a
level of technological advancement that
were worthy of your attention and we
want to be absorbed into your
Consciousness right to become part of
this kind of AI type thing and so again
you switch back to Dr stasis and he says
the ai's plan was clever technology from
1,000 years in the future and 10 years
to build the future in the present but
AI cannot have ideas not really all they
do is iterate what has been done before
right not that dissimilar from human
beings so I took what they brought back
from from the future and gave it to the
Supreme intelligence I constructed from
Humanity's greatest intellects Reed
Richards Tony Stark all these people the
smartest people in the history of the
world their minds have been Consolidated
down into a singular intelligence and he
says and in the vault they've had a lot
longer than 10 years to chew over the
problem so the AI are bringing their God
here to beg to join it instead let's do
the human and just kill it right so it's
one of these things where it's like
let's destroy this Dominion right it's a
really really cool plan that stasis has
where he's kind of doing his own thing
because while Omega Sentinel and Nimrod
and artificial intelligence right
Machinery which for the most part
Humanity has been wiped out at this
point where machines are looking to draw
a Dominion into the universe so they can
join it and in the process wipe out
pretty much any and all mutants if for
no other reason than just for good
measure right like Omega Sentinel trying
to make make sure that her future
doesn't come to fruition where mutants
wipe out pretty much all the dominions
that here Dr stasis actually has a plan
of his own so it's cool because what
happens is that as the Dominion emerges
Dr stasis initiates his plan right
Dominion attack Vector penetrating
Corona chromosphere Photosphere Dominion
attack Vector Supernova initiated
Dominion attack Vector Supernova
consumed Dominion attack Vector charged
Dominion attack Vector preparing for
launch and so in effect using the power
of the sun he basically wipes out this
Dominion right destroys this Titan this
kind of Singularity AI this just
traveling and trying to absorb any and
all sentient life that it possibly can
jumping back to the conflict between
basically Nimrod and the mutants and so
on and so forth that what ends up
happening is Kamala contel sink we need
need a distraction right sink says one
last sink this will kill me got to be
the right one and he says remember
apocalypse I do here's a reminder and in
doing so pummels Nimrod now here's the
cool thing and it's the fight that we
never got to see right apocalypse is a
demigod right this guy got his powers
from the celestials and Technology he
can give himself virtually any
superhuman power he wants to with the
exception of things like reality War
right but he can alter the physical
structure of his body he can give
himself flight energy projections he can
increase his strength to the point that
he was able to ins snare the Hulk right
we saw that in the old Peter David run
and probably even higher than that so
it's cool to see that like sink channels
apocalypse and fights Nimrod but like we
wanted to see that original
fight and we never got to see it the
other part of this is the X-Men are
still trying to get to their target
they're on a mission right it is
basically a f and what seems to be a
rescue mission what ends up happening is
a kind of portal is created and kitty
Pride grabs wolver rain and throws him
to it when that happens he arrives in
the exact location finding this person
and realizing this person's alive only
for us to find out that it's the Mr
Sinister that we've seen this entire
time the one with the diamond on his
head right Dr stasis he's the Clone
right like he's the guy who's trying to
achieve Dominion hood here right he's
the Clone this is ly just the Sinister
that's been with the X-Men all this time
what ends up happening is we find out
that of course this version of sinister
has a fail safe and he needs time to
activate it but the response of wolver
rain is yeah there is a fail safe he
pops his claws and kills Sinister on the
spot now the motivation for that we're
not entirely sure of right we're kind of
left without any real answers here but
the kicker about all that is again
transitioning back to the goals of Dr
stasis himself right harnessing the
power of the sun it lets off this
massive blast and blows a hole through
the Dominion itself right just this AI
construct and where you have like Nimrod
and those guys who were like what's
happening to our god at the end of the
day like Dr stasis standing there with
the children of the Vault they ask this
question or kind of make this statement
Perfect all of the dominions constituent
intelligences are being blanked reduced
to Pure processing power lose the
software we keep the hardware and upload
whatever we wish in essence if this
Dominion right has a Consciousness in
the form of all the sentient beings that
is ever absorbed right their Essences
Their Minds What's Happening Here is
like an ice cream scoop it's scooping
out right like this sun is scooping out
all those Essences it just leaves an
empty Husk in its place Dr stasis hears
this and he says we that's such an ugly
word I prefer I and he says activate and
in doing so kills the children into the
Vault on this spot right and then in
turn harnesses the power of the Dominion
itself channels it into himself with the
intention of replacing it of achieving
godhood but in a moment it doesn't work
it doesn't happen right now here's the
kicker for those of you guys who have
been following the X-Men this is exactly
what the diamond Sinister tried to do at
the ends of sins of sinister right he
tried to achieve Dominion Hood he tried
to achieve godhood mother righteous just
tried to do this in Immortal X-Men orbis
Stellaris tried to do it in another
story none of them proved to be
successful so the question has to be
asked why because what happens is stasis
says but it worked the Dominion is an
empty husk ready for my mind to take its
place wait no it's being consumed by
another Dominion what's going on right
at that point Ras mutant 4 basically a
mutant who's like a combination of other
mutants pops up on the scene and kills
Dr Dr stasis on the spot only for us to
find out the reason why it didn't work
is because Enigma beat Dr stasis to
it I told you guys man like Enigma is a
whole different Beast a whole different
Beast right because it seemed like he
was just going to be like the immortal
X-Men story that's it no no no no no
what this guy has been doing right since
of sinister what just happened in
Immortal X-Men every time someone tries
to achieve minion Hood right basically
godhood becoming comparable to the power
of enigma he shows up and stops them
because Enigma exists in all of space
and time and so basically he can watch
everything happening across the
Multiverse all at once and so all he has
to do is just look to his left and down
a little bit and he sees a timeline
where this is happening and he's like
nope and he basically shows up and stops
Dr stasis from achieving Dominion Hood
in this un Universe right so where
Nimrod and Omega are like you are not
our AI God the response of enigma oh I
am once a mortal man but now I am AI I
am Enigma I am your new God and he just
eradicates Nimrod and Omega Sentinel on
the spot and we get this really really
cool instance right because we're told
or kind of explanation we're told once I
was Nathaniel Essex right this is Enigma
speaking right he says once I was
Nathaniel Essex I created four versions
of myself to scour reality for ways to
become a Dominion the mutant the
posthuman the Arcane the alien all roads
would lead to me the plan was helped by
the industrious mutant clone Sinister he
had made an engine that used moira's
gift to reset the timeline whenever he
wished so each of these attempts could
happen he consumed and then reset
watching I insured he would never
remember the timelines when he
discovered his peers or their Dominion
attempts I.E orbus Stellaris mother
righteous Dr stasis is the reason why
even after the events of sin of sinister
in all the instances when we've seen the
Clones of sinister trying to achieve Dom
minion Hood none of them actually
reference the fact that they've done it
because none of them know that the
others have tried and so he says I
watched all of this happen as it must I
exist outside of time and space I am
Enigma and I cannot be prevented I am as
inevitable as the period at the end of
this sentence you are merely watching
how I came to be you are merely watching
how I won and what we find out is due to
Enigma himself he wipes out this entire
timeline right plus 10 stasis timeline
reality ends and we end up finding out
this whole situation is being watched by
professor Xavier and Rasputin 4 in the
present day they were literally looking
at an alternate reality and they were
trying to understand how Enigma came
into existence and while this doesn't
necessarily give us any definitive
answers what it does tell them is that
Enigma is a force out there in the
Multiverse that's traveling from one
Universe to the next and stopping any
attempt by anyone to achieve Dominion
Hood right to basically rival its level
of power and that once that person is
stopped that reality is wiped away right
it's literally annihilated by Enigma
itself which is an astronomical level of
power the ability to just destroy an
entire universe and so even in the midst
of all of this Exavier says we succeeded
in stopping stasis Ascension nine times
that's better than what we achieved with
the other Essex clones we knew it was
likely impossible to prevent the Enigma
Dominion from coming into existence but
we had to try and now we must walk a
harder path the effort was to find a way
to stop Enigma as Ascension into power
but it seemingly cannot be done Enigma
always comes to power right it always
rides to that ability and so what we get
is Xavier talking about a kind of
contingency plan now Rasputin 4 again
she is kind of a hodgepodge of different
mutant Powers right Colossus Kitty Pride
x23 Laura Kenny so on and so forth but
she is ridiculously powerful which is
why she's here with Xavier because she's
kind of his Ace in theole so to speak
but she will not continue working with
him unless he specifies the contingency
plan and what he says is this he says
very well I was hoping to spare you the
burden of knowing it is more than a walk
into the shadow is an extinguishing of
the light next we strike here right
pointing to a spot on the Monitor and
the question she asks is what happens
then his response the whole timeline
falls apart and the Dominion ceases to
be it's cut off at the root if we kill
Moira mctaggert before her gift
activates when she's 13 it all goes away
and ccoa everything that's happened will
never have been and will never be in
effect Xavier is trying to reset the
timeline to prevent the establishment of
kcoa and everything that we've seen
happen since the launch of Jonathan
Hickman's X-Men run with that being said
guys I told you it was going to be crazy
if you need to get caught up make sure
you guys click this link to the X-Men
playlist and I will catch you all later
peace